each week american history tv sits in on
a lecture with one of the nation's
college professors you can watch the
classes here every saturday at 8 pm and
midnight eastern and sundays at 1pm
coming up florida atlantic university
holocaust studies chair alan berger
discusses art spiegelman's graphic novel
mouse which depicts the author's
relationship with his father a holocaust
survivor
spiegelman composed his work not only
from conversations with his father but
from reading holocaust survivor accounts
in studying artwork by concentration
camp prisoners
florida atlantic university is in boca
raton
this class is an hour
[Music]
good morning good morning uh today we're
going to be speaking about a rather
special kind of holocaust representation
uh we're going to be speaking about art
spiegelman's mouse
which is a sensationally
new way
of representing the holocaust and its
continuing impact
on
successive generations
the future of holocaust memory and
jewish identity memory is
connected very specifically to identity
if you don't know your past you don't
know your present and you can't begin to
speculate about the future
i want to suggest that there has been a
major paradigm shift
from the writings of survivors
to
those of their descendants their
daughters and their sons
so as elie wiesel says
we leave the literature of testimony
the literature of testimony is what the
survivors are writing what they gave us
and we're going to
the second generation
what do we know about the second
generation generally
one thing we know
they inherit the trauma
and
the second generation is both the first
and the last that is to say the last
generation
that has contact physical contact with
the survivors their parents
and
they are the first
generation
the first generation born after the
holocaust and born into freedom
so they're the first and they are the
last
the second generation
got a very big impetus from a woman
named helen epstein
helen epstein is herself
a daughter of survivors in
czechoslovakia
in 1979
she published a book called children of
the holocaust children of the holocaust
epstein wrote an article about the
second generation
she sent it to the new york times
and they sent it back saying what is
this who's the second generation it
doesn't exist and it's not important
so much for newspapers
so
a little bit later
we have children of the holocaust what
did helen epstein do in that book she
interviewed people
daughters and sons of survivors
who lived in a variety of places in
north america europe and israel
all of whom were connected by their
relationship
to the holocaust
and all of whom were trying to figure
out exactly what that relationship was
they were just tiny portions
of
the legacy of the holocaust
because the most important event in
their lives happened before they were
born
and somehow they knew
the secret
for example
here's helen epstein
here's what she says about being a
daughter of survivors
for years it lay in an iron box buried
so deep inside me i was never sure just
what it was
i knew i carried slippery combustible
things more secret than sex and more
dangerous than any shadow or ghosts
ghosts had shape and name what lay
inside me was so potent that words
crumbled before they could describe
epstein says further they need to find a
way to channel the anger the sadness
the outrage into some kind of
constructive action
and she talks about being
obsessed by holocaust imagery for
example uh helen used to live in new
york city taught journalism at nyu
and she said frequently on the subway
train she used to imagine that as a
cattle car going to auschwitz
moreover when she would go to concerts
at carnegie hall
she would imagine that armed men with
machine guns would break in and start
killing people
inter-generational transmission of
trauma
questions about anything
okay
let's go
to
the main event
art spiegelman how many of you have
heard of him before this class
anybody else okay
uh spiegelman was born in itzhak avraham
ben ziv on february 15 1948 in stockholm
sweden
he's an american cartoonist editor
comics advocate based in new york city
best known for his graphic novel mouse
two volumes the second of which second
and final of which appeared in 1991.
now
um
spiegelman did extensive research before
embarking and while embarking during
this project
he
read survivor accounts
he
watched film footage but he said the
most important influence on him
was art
drawn by prisoners in the various
concentration and death camps he poured
over this art
because obviously that is his medium of
expression
one
initial comment
how do we read graphic novels
what's the difference between
a graphic novel
and a regular novel anybody know what's
the difference
yep
good good good good graphic novel has
images the images are supposed to be
telling us something
uh here's mouse 1 and mouse 2.
both graphic novels check out
the
subtitle
mouse one
my father bleeds history my father
bleeds history so
what's wrong with this title this
subtitle he's free but the subtitle and
here my troubles began
isn't that counterintuitive
after all auschwitz is behind him
and he's saying here my troubles began
why would that be yeah the fact that he
made it through and many others did not
well the attendant issue of survivor
guilt
and the fact that the
trauma continues
for example unlike stephen spielberg's
schindler's list
when the um
prisoners and the days of the holocaust
you see in black and white and suddenly
the war is over and it switches to color
remember that as if everything is cool
nothing to worry about
speaking of traumas i'm having a little
trouble with this but i'll work on it
uh
okay so mouse appears in 1991.
metamouse
is a retrospective look at mouse and it
was published in 2011
and metamouse is a complete package it's
a book it's got dvds you can watch
spiegelman's interview with vladik you
can
hear what he has to say in private
reflections
metamouse is worth looking at if you get
a chance
now
let's get to the big deal here the genre
issue
but what is the genre issue
i think it's
comic book is light and the comical and
it's the oxymoron of the horror of the
holocaust
okay by
lightness
that's certainly part of it let me
suggest another part
for spiegelman
comics
c-o-m-i-c-s
is broken down into
co-mix
that's the graphic novel co-mix
a mixture of images and words
unlike a regular novel co-mix
what else is the genre issue here
and we're going to return to this comics
comics issue a little bit later what
else is going on here
yep the depiction of
the characters
very good the depiction of the
characters as animals
what animals
good who was who
don't forget reindeers too
yeah
what who is who who are the main
characters
who are depicted as
mice and
germans as cats yes germans as cats
everybody in the world knows about the
relationship between mice and cats
it's not a very good one
it's like woody allen says the lion
shall lie down with the lamb but the
lamb will have a very restless night
dog cats and mice
yeah not so much they don't get along
too well
okay now
um there was a major major discussion
argument about the use of animal
figures
but let me say this first
spiegelman's book is the single most
influential second generation
work that we have
it won a pulitzer prize
and there was a controversy over where
this book should be listed on the best
seller list
should it be fiction or should it be
non-fiction the new york times at first
listed it under the fiction category
spiegelman objected
vigorously and they changed it to the
non-fiction category because it's
non-fiction it's both as we heard a
biography
of vladic and anja and mala
and an
autobiography of art spiegelman
he's writing and drawing himself into
this
graphic novel because
it's like this
how would you like to be the second set
of children born to job the biblical
character
how would that be growing up in that
house
i know we have a hollywood ending in the
bible but that ending is extraneous to
the story what would it be like
to be
a replacement child as if there could
ever be a replacement child
that's the issue here
that's one of the issues that spiegelman
confronts
okay
here's the controversy
first the people who say it's a good
thing
that
spiegelman did lawrence langer is a
distinguished literary critic
and he says what it's a serious form of
pictorial literature sustaining and even
intensifying the power of the first
volume he reviewed the volume 2 in the
new york times
perhaps no holocaust narrative will ever
contain the whole experience but art
spiegelman has found an original and
authentic form to draw us closer to its
bleak heart
he's saying that the animal forms
invite us rather than repel us
what do you think about that is that
true
in your experience
it's very inviting
i think so i think so
um
it is it draws us in
and makes us part of the story as well
uh anybody else want to see it yeah it
doesn't seem to have the personal
connection that it would be if it
portrayed humans rather than animals
interesting that emotional yeah yeah but
if it doesn't have a personal connection
what uses it to us as readers
representative
representation representation of the
continuing impact of the holocaust on
the survivor
and
the survivor's offspring okay lori did
you want to say something i felt the
opposite i felt that i could relate more
because they're mice and i felt
it would make it easier for everyone to
relate yeah i think that's not opposite
i think that's
uh opposite i think that that's a breed
yeah i think when you start reading it
you kind of kind of you know spark some
curiosity like how the author is going
to portray them in a truthful way yeah
so it does uh draw us into the the
narrative and certainly the image
now jeffrey hartman a distinguished
literary critic
now emeritus at yale university
expands the um
the idea of the use of animals
the metamorphosis of the human figure
recognizes that the shoah the holocaust
has affected how we think about
ourselves as a species the human
question mark race
what's the difference between humans and
animals
uh is this how humans operate
well evidently yes so it
problematizes
all of the
exhortations about the uh
the glory and the beauty of humanity you
know a little lower than the angels well
quite a bit lower
terence dupray
says something else about
mouse and its use of animal figures
mouse is a family romance he says
replete with guilt and unresolved
complexities caused by the hold of the
past
upon the present
the kind of knowledge of suffering that
cannot be dismissed but only shared in
the survivor's tale before us
so are you persuaded by these three
observations
please say yes
good okay because now i want to go
to
the objections
objections to mouse the most powerful of
the objections
was stated by hillel halcon hello
is a a an american who made aliyah moved
to israel many years ago and is himself
a distinguished literary critic
and what does he say about
mouse
he doesn't like it
he says the following drawing people
as animals is doubly dehumanizing
what does he mean
by virtue of symbolism and by
virtuographic limitations what about
symbolism
he says this haven't the nazis already
dehumanized the jews enough
haven't they already tortured beaten
starved and murdered them
dehumanized them why do we need animals
one argument
second argument
graphic limitation for how can
excuse me
um
animal
faces simply are not expressive enough
human faces are far more expressive
what do you think about this argument
yep
doesn't it make it easier
i i disagree with that because i feel
good it makes it easier for the average
maybe non-jewish person to relate
to the comic with animals and
interesting yeah
so you you break it down between jewish
non-jewish
that's an interesting painful to see
less expression on an animal's face than
to see a human's face suffer so much
that's probably so so easier for
everyone to read okay good but is it
true
are animal faces unexpressive
how many people here own a pet aside
from a husband or what okay so
um
what do you say
yep judy i think the animal faces were
more expressive i got more emotion i
felt more emotion
from looking at those
you know mice that were
being on them
oh i think i think animal faces can be
quite expressive yeah worry i think it
does make it more expressive and as an
example people find faces in like
pieces of toast
or something you know and then it
becomes a big deal so i think as humans
we
look like it's universal we look for a
face
it makes it easier because everything
else is blank like there is it yeah i
think certainly that's uh the argument
that
professor cheney of dartmouth university
makes that we look for faces
we can relate to faces
maybe because of
some narcissistic reasons but we look at
faces
we just can't resist that
and the question here is
is the animal face
expressive or is it not expressive
i get the sense of the meeting here that
most folks think that the animal face
can be quite expressive
as well as the observation that
um
non-jewish people
may be able to relate more
if it's presented in
the co-mix form
yep i kind of agree with hillel because
then we are remind decided seeing the
story we're saying yeah they are like
animals like a cute little sad story but
it's it's like a movie like hollywood
movie you're not portraying the real
thing and you want to show the reality
so it won't happen again
interesting
so
um
what can we say
we have arguments on both sides of the
issue
which is good it means that the
holocaust continues to generate
controversy
which it should
continues to
engage us
as it should
somebody else had a question
yes sir i just want to say that
nothing has ever expressed the
uh
pain and suffering as the faces of the
survivors on film black and white film
that was taken
on liberation
on uh when the cancer lived right
so you you're agreeing with hillary
hawkins position yeah
all right all right
any other comments about these
two diametrically opposed
conditions i hope yeah
well i think that one of the advantages
of this form is that it introduces the
material to an entirely different
audience
um i think the the application of the
graphic artistry allows people who are
very visual
to see the story in a way that they can
relate to that they may not pick up from
just having words or just from a from a
film i think it creates another audience
yeah i think that's a good point and we
might summarize it by saying it
universalizes the story
people who pick up on graphic cues
more than uh the written word certainly
everybody as i said before everybody in
the world knows about the relationship
between mice and cats and it causes us
to reflect
on the issues that are raised here i
think that's true let me move on
okay
some of the psychological issues that we
find
in mouse and indeed in the entire range
of second generation
literature the lack of parental
boundaries and we're going to return to
these shortly the lack of the validation
of children's emotional needs
the role of silence
on children and parents not asking
questions because they fear hurting each
other
when in fact what you don't know is
frequently a lot more scary than what
you do know
over protectiveness
images of survivors on the one hand
my father's a hero he survived the
holocaust
on the other hand
good lord look at the way he dresses
like a real immigrant
looks terrible and besides he talks
funny
all of these issues are issues which
survivors
their
offspring need to confront and they
confront them in a variety of ways
any questions about these
points
which are in fact
definitive of second generation
literature
um
lack of validation of children's
emotional needs
oh you don't want to eat your vegetables
i saw my mother starve to death in
auschwitz
that's not exactly a comforting image
lack of parental boundaries
let me see how i can interfere in your
life more
now parents are known for not
understanding anything anyway
we all know that until we grow up and
become parents
but
the lack of the
willingness or ability
to say
okay you want to go out on a date fine
go enjoy yourself
but
don't forget
if there is flawed parenting and
parenting is a difficult enough task in
any case
let alone after you survive the
holocaust remember one thing
at the time when
the survivors were supposed to be
learning parenting skills they were in
auschwitz
not exactly a good place to learn how to
nurture people
not exactly a good place to learn how to
express love comfort and encouragement
sure there's flawed parenting
what else would you expect
okay
i want to touch briefly on this this is
a holocaust story but yet what do we
know
about the role of english
surprising
at least in two ways
remember in mouse 1
he
is called what is called the sheik
what's a sheik vladic is called the
sheep
in volume one
s-h-e-i-k what is a sheik
as opposed to c-h-i-c what's a sheik
a nobleman a nobleman
and a ladies man
and how does a vladic meet anja anyway
remember
in volume one
what do they mean somebody fixes them up
yeah and what language do they speak
english
i'll give you a clue
english english
in poland
so
they have a relationship based on the
fact that both of them speak english
how bizarre
in poland
okay
now what about the second point english
as life-saving
how do we know that
yeah
that was uh with the
capo in um
one of the camps yeah
and
he wanted to learn english yes so he
found out that
atlantic
spoke english and that saved him because
he
gave him food in exchange for teaching
okay
one way we know english is life-saving
is that
vladic
teaches a capital capo a guard
english in return for extra food rations
literally life-saving
english becomes the inadvertent language
of holocaust representation
vladic speaks english
but of course in a
refugee-cadenced way you know he's a
refugee and not a native speaker
if you want to know more about this
issue of english as the language of the
holocaust which strikes one is quite
bizarre i recommend that a very good
book by alan rosen
r-o-s-e-n
called
sounds of defiance sounds of defiance
our library has it
professor rosen raises very interesting
points about how suddenly
english becomes the language of the
holocaust again all
intuitive
ways of looking at this it's
counter-intuitive questions about
anything
okay let's move on
religion
religion you know they say you should
never talk about politics or religion if
you want to have a good time at a party
what do we know about religion
in
mouse
especially of course with
vladic
well he talks a lot about something
called parsha truma parsha is a weekly
reading
the weekly biblical reading
aparsha truma is the time
of important events in this book
for example remember vladik is first
imprisoned in a german prisoner of war
camp
he has a dream
what's his dream
the dream is that
he's visited by someone that's like a
rabbi and the the what do you mean like
a rabbi i know there's no like there's
no like it's either a rabbi or it isn't
in this case it is not who is it
who is it his father father
uh-huh uh-huh
um
actually it's not his father it's his
grandfather oh sorry
both of us will stay after school okay
so what do we know about the grandfather
anyway
well he tells him
that he
he will be set free from this camp yes
on the day of parshat
good
uh and we know of course that the
grandfather is quite religious
and his prediction comes true
vladick is freed
on the day of the reading of the portion
trump
but other important events occur on this
day too
vladick and anja are married
on this date remember
um
art spiegelman is born on this date
mart spiegelman has his bar mitzvah
he coming of age a rite of passage on
this date
so this becomes an important
entree
into
the religious life although
vladic says something interesting about
our old friend
[Music]
remember
this one
what does he say you know that one what
does he say about god
what does vladic say
about god when he's being interviewed by
art
yep
he wasn't there
yes
god was not there
atlantic says in auschwitz god did not
come we were all on our own he says
now you might want to mentally compare
that to what elie wiesel has suggested
that in auschwitz
god was um
there was no speculation about god god
might in fact be an exploration of soup
that would be god
so clearly
vladic when he said god didn't come and
auschwitz wasn't there is talking about
a traditional image of god
not
what god became in auschwitz at least
for some people okay questions
all right let's move on
righteous gentile here's an interesting
concept
what do we know about
this
there are two righteous gentiles in
auschwitz
who are they
there are two of them
neither of whom is named by the way
who are they
and what did the priest say
was the priest the one that saw his arm
in the numbers and told him he was going
to
live yes
good
the priest says
he knew hebrew and he said
you
will
live
he tells artie that is uh or rather
vladic
that his number tattooed on his arm
is equivalent to the hebrew word for
life
and the priest serves as a seer
flattick says i never saw the priest
again but when i met him that first and
only time i was so depressed i was so
upset i was feeling
completely hopeless he literally saved
my life
by telling me that i would live
and there's another righteous gentile in
the story announcements who is that
madison the woman that was the mediator
between vladiq and anja
well yeah but in addition there's
somebody even more important who is that
again nameless
nameless
and again not jewish
a prophet
a prophet a prophet
what do you mean
somebody that could uh oh yeah but this
is a particular person
who is it
remember the french prisoner of war
not jewish so therefore he could receive
food packages from the outside
and what happened
he and vladik became friends
and
he was sustained by the friendship with
the
french prisoner much like primo levy
in
survival in auschwitz was sustained by
his relationship
with a non-jew
who brought him food
lorenzo
and who spoke to him who treated him
like a human being
so the french
prisoner
became friends with vladimir and and
shared his full graces
yes
but he did it because
the french guy knew english yes
and
that's the way he another example you're
absolutely right great
because they spoke english
another example of english as
a life-saving language take a look at
professor rosen's book
okay
so vladic's earlier assertion that we
were all alone and nobody cared
not quite true
priest
french prisoner
okay
let us continue
bless you
mouse
here is a perfect perfect example
of
how
the child's emotional needs
are simply
not validated
remember this scene
marty
comes back
from skating with his friends
and he fell and
scraped his knees friends laughed at him
and skated away so he reports this to
vladimir
and
what does vladic say
friends your friends
if you lock them together in a room with
no food for a week
then you could see what it is friends
what a bizarre thing to tell a
ten-year-old child
not exactly comforting thought
not exactly a way to trust the outsider
social world indeed why should a
survivor trust such a world
and you see what happens
small bricks here you go down and down
on the last one
the bricks are overwhelming maybe
they're in prison is a suggestion
graphic novels do have an advantage
okay
let's move on
time flies here's artie
with his um mouse mast what do you say
glad whoops sorry
flattick died of congestive heart
failure
on august 18th 1982 francois his wife
and i stayed with him in the catskills
back in august 1979. juxtaposing
dates important dates in the life of his
father and in holocaust with his own
life what days
um
over 100 000 hungarian jews were gassed
in auschwitz
what a juxtaposition
talk about intergenerational
transmission of trauma my god
in september 1986 after eight years of
work the first part of mouse was
published was a critical and commercial
success
and now look what happens here
he's at his drawing board at least 15
foreign editions are coming out i've
gotten four serious offers to turn my
book into a tv special movie i don't
wanna
in may 68 my mother killed herself left
no note lately i've been feeling
depressed hi mr speaker we're ready to
shoot
now
here is the pile of corpses
mouse corpses
as you go down the page
and the image gets larger you see the
corpses
much larger in proportion than artie and
what does this mean we're ready to shoot
he means ready to shoot the movie
spiegelman thinks ready to shoot
the the jews
it's a very clever inventive way of
getting the message across of holocaust
imagery impact on the second generation
questions
okay let us continue
um
here is
a very interesting panel which we'll get
to in one moment
as soon as i get my notes together
okay
what's going on here well
artie is speaking to francois
reminiscing about his childhood
and what's he saying
talks about his ghost brother
he got killed before
i was born
he was only five or six
after the war my parents trade
traced down the
vegas rumors and tried to recover their
child child was given to an aunt who
poisoned him
rather than her and herself and her own
children rather than have them go to a
camp
i didn't think about him very much when
i was growing up
he was mainly a large blurry photograph
hanging in my parents bedroom
i thought that was a picture of you she
says
um though it didn't look like you that's
the point they didn't need photos of me
in their room i was alive
they didn't talk about rishu but the
photo was a kind of reproach he'd have
become a doctor
and married a wealthy jewish girl and
career
but at least we could have made him
go deal with ladder
it's spooky having sibling rivalry with
a snapshot
from this we get the message of the
impossible comparison
the living child cannot possibly
be as perfect as accomplished
as achievement fulfilled as the dead
child would have been
but of course the dead child is
idealized
idealized
this is an issue for many in the second
generation
artie is a second only son
a second only son because the first one
died in the holocaust what does it mean
to be a second only child how many of
you are only children
okay
what do you think about being a second
only child what kind of
psychological
burden does that impose on
the child
whatever the child does
it's not good enough
not good enough okay let us um
proceed to the next
this seems like a simple thing
but it's not
arty is visiting vladic and mala his
second wife and he asked for his he's
getting ready to leave and he says uh no
i don't want many coffee just my coat oh
dad have you seen my coat anywhere yes i
threw it out
what
you're kidding give it back it's too
late
when you were sitting first down to
dinner
i threw it in the garbage can by now the
garbage man took it away
flattick decides the coat is no good so
he throws it out
talk about lack of respect for
boundaries
he just threw the code out
not consulting already not caring about
what artie might think about it he
throws it up
okay
now
this i think is
noteworthy
uh vladic is remembering when they told
the time that they took his own parents
and never to be seen again
those with a stamp
were led to go home but there are very
few jews now left and sosnuts
one from three they kept at the stadium
maybe ten thousand people and with them
my father
all murdered
and then
in a very very good juxtaposition of
psychic and physical exhaustion what
does he show there's vladic on the
exercise
he can't go on anymore he is depleted
physically and emotionally and you get
that feeling don't you when you see this
here's a man who's exhausted he's
exhausted physically from his workout
but he's exhausted psychically from the
memory of the murder of his parents
i think it's very clever
now
let us move on
for the first time and only time in the
two volumes we get a brief four-page
insert
called prisoner on the hell planet what
do we note about this insert
what strikes you first of all
good the animals have disappeared we're
dealing with humans here
as a matter of fact
this is a picture of anja
his mom
prisoner on the hell planet
what happens artie has spent some time
in a mental hospital he's released he
comes home
and
he finds that his mother is dead she's a
suicide a suicide
his father is distraught of course
and each of them says a prayer
vladic
says
the qaddish the prayer for the dead in
hebrew
what does arnie say
he chants from the tibetan book of the
dead you might say he is
alienated from the jewish tradition to
put it mildly okay
then comes something else
um
among the words of comfort
is the accusation you did it you killed
her
you weren't attentive enough you didn't
say i love you
it's your fault in other words
and then we have this
very interesting thing
picture of a mother in a bathtub where
she slashed her wrist
menopausal depression hitler did it
mommy and [ __ ]
and the memory of his mother coming into
his bedroom asked if he loves her says
yeah sure ma
and then she leaves
and then he finds himself as a prisoner
prisoner
congratulations you've committed the
perfect crime
and here it works here in prison
and the other prisoners say pipe down
mac you're making too much noise
which i interpret as spiegelman's
saying
that there is widespread indifference
about holocaust memory
or the impact of the holocaust on
contemporary life
just shut up you're making too much
noise too much noise
okay now
let's see
oh good
i think i want to pause for a moment on
behalf of all of us and express undying
thanks to bonnie lander
and dennis hall for getting this slide
in at the last possible second
each of them have earned not only a
place in heaven but a free starbucks
card okay what's happening here i know
we've got it on record um
what's going on here
artie goes to see pavel p-a-v-e-o who's
pavel anyway
pavel is a psychiatrist and what else is
powerful
survivor
survivor psychologist artie's feeling
depressed how can i continue i i need i
don't know what to do
and what is what happens there's
something very interesting the papal
says in this slide
he took his guilt out on you where it
was saved
you are the real survivor
that's bizarre
pavel
the survivor psychologist says to artie
you are the real survivor
why is arty the real survivor
because he survived
vladic's rage atlantic's
inability to work through his own
holocaust inheritance and took it all
out on artie arty's a survivor
he survived that kind of childhood
question
yes also
it's saying that vladik isn't a survivor
because even though he's been liberated
he's not free but he's never good
good
there's a difference between
leaving the holocaust physically as an
historically anchored event
and
living afterward with that psychic
trauma
and elie wiesel i think said it best for
the survivors
the holocaust continued after the
holocaust the holocaust continued after
the holocaust okay i think there's one
other thing here with
um
powerful
artie is feeling stuck in his creative
work
goes to see pebble now what happens here
um
[Music]
how did auschwitz feel what auschwitz
was like hmm
and suddenly
pablo says boo
big black bold letters boo
and look at the difference in the size
of the figures
pavel you can tell is an adult look at
arnie
what is arnie
a child
a child
the survivor and the child but at least
what artie gets from going to see pavel
is some idea about being validated as a
son of survivors
and
understanding that the holocaust
is an unmastered and unmasterable trauma
you can't depict it
it's unmasterable you can do
your best you can try
you can perhaps
give some indication
but you can't contain it it's just too
overwhelming
okay let's continue
here is the last page of the book now
what do we see here
well
um vladimir is talking about his
experience
says
he and anja are reunited after the war
we lived happily ever after is that true
they did not live happily ever after
vladic was um
miserly mean-spirited
yelling and screaming all the time my
wife tells me i do the same and they
weren't too happy although my wife and i
are happy so what happens
at the end near the end he says this
so let's stop please your tape recorder
says vladic doherty
i'm tired from talking rishu
calls artie the name of his dead son
and it's enough stories for now
calling artie rishu
is an example of what lawrence langer
the literary critic we mentioned earlier
calls deep memory
deep memory as opposed to the memory of
the chronological memory
well this morning i got up i had
breakfast i went to this crazy class
after it i'm going to have coffee it'll
feel normal again
chronological memory deep memory
memory that cannot be exercised
and what do we know here from here
the last image
uh 1982 he dies in 19 uh atlantic 1968.
anja spiegelman draws this book from
1978 to 1991
13 years a bar mitzvah
what is a bar mitzvah mean literally
means son of commandments it means you
assume adult responsibility
you become fully a jewish person
bar mitzvah for a male bot mitzvah for a
female
drawing this cartoon this this um
impossibly brilliant
cartoon book mouse has made hardy
a man
he's assumed his role
as a
functioning
adult
who
says yes i can now affirm my jewish
identity what that identity means we'll
see in a moment questions
okay let's continue
what about what about the american
connection for mouse after all
we live in america why should we care
well a couple of things
there is the popularity of comic strips
such as disney's mickey mouse bugs bunny
porky pig who wasn't kosher but still
very popular
why in fact vladick was so excited about
the project in the beginning is that he
thought well it's a comic book like
mickey mouse everybody will love it
thereby completely missing the point but
that's beside the point um
one thing
comics an american medium
above all
second
comics can be a medium for reflecting on
matters of serious concern
matters of serious concern aline
kaminsky krum for example and her
comics that deal with jewish feminist
issues
comics can be
a medium for expressing and exploring
matters of very serious concern no
question about it
and what about the last thing
the role of comics in the early history
of american newspapers
i'm sure you've all seen a newspaper
right i mean it's a dying phenomenon but
newspapers used to be very important
and
in order for them to sell
they had comics
one
why
because there was a high
rate of illiteracy in america
used to be now it's probably higher but
that's another point
comics you don't need to be able to read
comics you can visually see
and you can laugh you can cry you can
you can get involved in things
so comics have a long history
in american cultural history
they're very expressive and by the way
they helped sell newspapers
which wasn't a bad thing either
questions
yep
comics were read by every child i mean
and it also taught you how to read
yes but it was a very popular
part of the newspaper very popular part
of a newspaper some people used to go to
two sections only the comics and the
sports
i still do
but
comics as a way of
inviting people in of buying the
newspaper of being entertained
absolutely okay let us go
to
this issue
identity
in the postmodern world one of the major
major
issues
of post-modernity which is the era in
which we all live
is the issue of identity
it has
become
the lead motif
of american culture who am i the culture
is changing the demographics are
changing
is that a good thing is that a worrisome
thing is it something to be embraced is
it something that's threatening it's all
of those things
the concern for identity is a hallmark
of
post-modernity
also
the formation of special identity groups
their second generation clubs there are
um
vietnam war veterans there's alcoholics
anonymous all kinds of groups that have
formed that deal with identity
um
in fact i want to make several points
here
when spiegelman was younger he thought
it wasn't such a good idea to be a jew
and indeed why would he think it would
be
because all he was hearing were stories
about
jews being rounded up
and murdered
many in the second generation when they
were younger
were frightened to be jews
it was a terrible thing
the implication was
i'm next
what are they going to do to me
so clearly
that is understandable
however however there are several
important things
vladic did insist that already have a
bar mitzvah that is a central rite of
passage for jewish
young jewish boys
secondly
artie's wife francoise molay
converts to judaism
why
to please flattick
to please let it
um
moreover
mouse one
the first volume is dedicated to anja
arty's wife
mouse ii
is dedicated to reshoo
the murder child
and to nadja
francois and artie's daughter
connection between the first generation
and the third generation
nadja is a grandchild
clearly
vladic
has embraced this jewish
identity business but he's embraced it
on his own terms
um
i want to read a quote from artie
i am he says very completely a jew
and that has been driven home
by having to understand what happened to
my parents
nothing about religion
nothing at all
it's ethnic
this is similar to what the survivor
writer primo levy once said
i am a jew it's been stamped into me in
auschwitz by my
tattooed number
arty essentially is saying the same
thing it's been imprinted on me
by the intergenerational transmission of
trauma
that's why i'm a jew
forget the covenant forget the
commandments forget all of that
religious business i'm a jew i know that
but what happened to my parents
and finally
he says this
my identity he says is a kind of
diaspora alienation
that comes with the imposition of an
identity
i'm in the diaspora i'm not in israel
diaspora is a greek word meaning
scattered about
my identity is imposed on me
maybe i don't want it
but man it's sure here
posed on me as sure as the clothes i'm
wearing the air i'm breathing the food
i'm eating
it's imposed on me
i am a jew
look at what happened to my parents
and finally he says this
if if my
mouse volumes
make people think of that moment
the holocaust
and its consequences
i am proud of that
i'm happy if people
can perhaps stop and reflect
on the holocaust and its consequences
that's a pretty tall order but that i
think is what he wants to do
okay
now we have some time for questions
yes sir is it it also is concurrently
when israel became a
real military power and i think that uh
it was easier to
psychologically emotionally
be because
they were doing the israelis were doing
something doing something positive
against the enemies of judaism that's
true however however
there's a couple of things to be noted
at no point in mouse one or mouse two do
we get anything about israel
one thing
second
i don't think spiegelman thinks it's
easy to be a jew
i think he thinks it's very difficult
because of the trauma that he's
inherited
and that he has learned about
and the other thing we need to
understand
is this
many in the second generation including
spiegelman when they were young
pre-teenagers teenagers
they heard just bits and pieces of
stories
and they heard these stories
uh that were referred to or spoken about
in yiddish frequently which the kids
didn't understand
and they heard just snatches of
conversation which they made they
understood and were frightened by
it's only when they themselves
got married
had a family that they could sit down
and interview their parents and get a
whole
connected
narrative
so i think that what you said about
israel is correct to a point
i think it's irrelevant in spiegelman's
own
coming to grips with flatic story
with his own story
and how the two are intertwined
flattick's biography becomes
spiegelman's autobiography
you are the real survivor says pavel
more questions please yes um well i
thought it was interesting when nala
the second one second wife she was
saying that not all survivors are like
vatic
and what did she
i mean i guess
well they don't all go to the grocery
store and return like boxes of cereal or
something but um what else
what else could you say like survivors
um
characterize survivors good question
good question
um
[Music]
not all survivors are like vladic
what was vladic like
he was a miser
he was a racist
he was mean-spirited
and he was a survivor
he was innovative he was resourceful
he wasn't sure fully human
now
survivors vary in characteristics
obviously
and it depends pretty much on what their
pre-war personalities were which we have
no idea of knowing because there were
never any studies done on that
and it depends on what kind of
situations they were in during the war
those who were in death camps tend to be
more morose
less trustful those who are fighting
with the partisans tend to be
outgoing tend to be very proud of what
they did
they're representing their experiences
as heroic as indeed they were
but if you want a
very good book about survivors
william helm reich
i h-e-l-m-r-e-i-c-h a book called
against all odds
holocaust survivors and the successful
lives they lived in america
some became millionaires
some became great philanthropists
others did
social welfare projects flattick
was a mixed bag
difficult to live with
however he took all of the coping skills
that he developed in the camp
and utilized them after the holocaust
who survived who returns a half
eaten box of cereal good question
good question
if you want to extend this further
ask not about vladic but about artie
already in the mental hospital
start saving string
in case he might need it later just like
vladic star was hoarding string and
other things this is a mimetic
repetition on the part of the second
generation
of what the survivor generation did and
you know when freud talks about trauma
he talks about repetition
that's what this money many in the
second generation have done
in helen epstein's book children of the
holocaust one of her examples is a
son of survivors named al
singerman
singerman joined the war in vietnam
because he wanted to put himself in a
dangerous situation just like his
survivor parents were in a dangerous
situation in the camp
a mimetic
repetition
of the original trauma yes madison i
thought it was interesting that vladick
actually suffered second generation
drama from his father going into the war
and how he would starve and deprive his
sons of sleep
before they joined yeah yeah absolutely
um the trauma of the survivors
is well documented
and the issue unfortunately
is that it's um one of their legacies
passed on to the second generation
there is
trauma unbound and then there is the
attempt to work through
the trauma of scholars such as dominic
lecapra
ellen fine talk about working through
what is working through me
it doesn't mean
the kind of stuff that you hear on the
news every day
resolution closure
closure is one of those five cent
throwaway words that has no meaning
it means this
it means being able to talk about the
trauma without being paralyzed by it
it means somehow being able to
detoxify it sufficiently
so that you can function as a human
being it doesn't mean forgetting and
we've spoken about forgetting and
forgiving in here in the past doesn't
mean forgetting
it means being able to move on with your
life
recognizing that this is a part of
an irreducible
fundamental part of your life
but moving on and being able to function
normally and well
in society that's what
working through means not forgetting
more questions
yep wouldn't you say then that um
mouse 102 was art spiegelman's way of
working through his trauma and that's
why at the end the reference
to him being um
bar mitzvahed
and his growth through his experience of
writing the book is what helped him
become a man
not only would i say that
if i knew how to get to the top of the
roof here i would climb to the roof and
i would shout it out yes ma'am
the other thing i would say is this
writing mouse is a way that arty had of
continuing his relationship with
vladimir
very important atlantic is dead and gone
however i want to continue
i want to see if i can
get to understand him more and by
understanding him more i can get to
understand myself more
very important
and this is also a reason for writing
this book and you're 100 right it is
artie's way of working through his
inheritance good point
more questions
more questions
yes i just had an observation about the
the mother's suicide
yeah yeah she originally she had
suicidal ideation early on
and when when they first met vladic and
and anja he's going through her pills
marking down every pill she
took
and then finding out what it was for and
one of them was for nerves which we
would probably consider like
anxiety today
so she already had sort of a
predisposition then you find out near
the end that the her brother had
committed suicide
over a girlfriend or some kind of love
of there and of course the sister
committed suicide with the kids which is
a different scenario but suicide you
know now also brings in families
she had a predisposition to suicide she
was she had many suicidal thoughts there
were some attempts
as you point out the family had an
unfortunate history of this
she was i guess you might say we might
say today unstable
and she had this issue that she had to
work through
and certainly vladic
um
how shall i say this delicately
was less than useless when it came to
providing emotional support and sukhoi
for
anja no question about it but that's an
important point she had this
predisposition absolutely yes
something interesting is vladic was you
know the example was friends you know
see what it is friends but then he gives
like this ultimate example of friendship
where ange's in the camp and
she was
like basically she vladic
was giving her food packages and then
nanja came to get it and then she got
caught
um i guess it was a capital or something
that she
chased after her wanted to kill her she
was searching for her
for
days or they had um
when they came outside and doing like
the
what the
what is it the barracks
yeah they um the capital made them like
jump and do all these things
and said one of you did it i know one of
you did it but
basically
none of her friends like put her out
there
there was an example of solidarity in
the camps but let's face it
before we condemn vladic too much
he really loved anja he risked his life
on numerous occasions to get her food
that's a good use of a four-letter word
l-o-v-e
and he did
he did all that he was incredibly
resourceful
he was incredibly brave and he was
incredibly successful so i think we
should remember that too
one more question
who would like to ask the last question
yes
there's a report that
black
vladimir
he did black work he did uh digging and
moving rocks
did he call it black work because he
believed that only african americans
were supposed to be doing that type of
work or is it um what the survivors
called up camp slang camp slang
just like
in camp slang those prisoners who had
given up all hope
and were just waiting to be
sent to the gas chambers were called
mother
muslims cam slam
thank you all very much for your good
questions we will meet on thursday
oh
[Music]
join us each saturday at